لا طيره في زياره الحلفاء قد يستسل قولها
غير عارف بسياق هذا الحراك الغربي في
منطقه شرق اسيا والمحيط الهادي الى
المنطقه المتوتره امنيا في الاساس يحمل
وزير الدفاع الامريكي رساله دعم ثابت
لكوريا الجنوبيه وبقيه الشركاء
لا يقف الامر كما يبدو عند القرار المنتخب
بتوسيع المستوى التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه ونطاقها وتمت تحالفات ستتعزز بل
قد تتخذ اشكالا جديده مختلفه
ليس سرا ان الامريكيين يروغون كبحا نفوذ
الصيني المتصاعد الطامح في رايهم للهيمنه
وليس اقل عزما على مواجهه ما يرونه
تهديدات متزايده من كوريا الشماليه
للاستقرار العالمي لم تتبدل اذن
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الامريكيه وحده
المعطى النووي دخل على الخط ليعزز اجراءات
الرضع التقليديه لحمايه الحلفاء
عن جمهوريه السابق الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ملتزمه
وهذا يشمل القدرات الامريكيه الكامله بما
في ذلك القدرات الدفاعيه التقليديه
والنوويه والصاروخيه
في شمال الاطلسي في طريقه كما يبدو لبناء
ما يشبه حلفا نيته بصيغه اسيويه
في ظل العقيده الدفاعيه اليابانيه الجديده
مع اليابان لمواجهه ما يقول انها التحديات
العالميه التي تشكلها الحرب الروسيه
الاقرانيه
هنا حيث التوتر وهناك في الحرب مترابط
بشكل وثيق لكنه بيان ايضا لخريطه المحاور
التي تضع روسيا والصين وكوريا الشماليه في
مواجهه الغرب وحلفائه الاسيويين يذهب
الامين العام لحلف الناتو ابعد حين يقول
ان حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وتعاونها
العسكريه المتنامي مع الصين او جداء ما
وصفها باخطر بيئه امنيه منذ حرب العالميه
الثانيه كلمات كفيله باستفزاز بيجينغ وهم
يراقبون بقلق التحركات الغربيه في محيطهم
يؤكد الصينيون بان تلك التحركات عينها هي
ما قد يجلب نظر الحرب الى المنطقه